[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 300 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
بايدن يستعجل هجوما اوكرانيا مضادا خوفا
من عرقله جمهوريه للمساعدات
يضغط من اجل المقاتلات
من عواقب خططها لتزويد موسكو باسلحه
وتقارير ترصد تدفق المسيرات عبر طرف ثالث
تسع محافظات تركيه تلقي الرايه البيضاء في
جهود الانقاذ واسطنبول المهدده تسابق
الزمن لتامين مبانيها
لدينا ايضا
بلومبر تنقل عن دبلوماسيين قولهم ان ايران
خصبت يورانيوم بنسبه
84% ما يقربها من السلاح النووي
في تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا كشفت صحيفه
بوليتيكو عن ان اداره بايدن طلبت من
اوكرانيا تعزيز مكاسبها العسكريه
والاستعداد لشن هجوم مضاد على القوات
الروسيه السبب هو خوف الاداره من عدم
قدرتها على ارسال مساعدات جديده بسبب
عراقيل الجمهوريين واوضحت الصحيفه ان
مساعدي بايدن بحثوا زيارته لاوكرانيا قبل
ان يتم استبعاد الفكره
وبينما تضغط واشنطن على من اجل الهجوم
المضاد يضغط هو من اجل المقاتلات مشرعون
امريكيون كشفوا عن ان مسؤولين اوكرانيين
طالبوا اعضاء في الكونغرس بالضغط على
اداره بايدن لارسال مقاتلات اف 16 الى
واشارت مصادر لروتورز الى ان وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني ذمتروكوليبا التقى
باعضاء ديموقراطيين وجمهوريين بمجلسي
النواب والشيوخ على هامش مؤتمر يونيخ
للامن فيما اكد سنتر ماركلي وثلاثه من
المشرعين الاخرين
عقد لقاءات مع المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
مشيرين الى تنامي الراي الداعم لتزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه المقاتلات
عجله الحرب في اوكرانيا لا تتوقف عن
الدوران فصول اربعه عاشتها المعركه في
انتظار فصل خامس
كيف تستعد لصد هجوم روسي محتمل خلال
الربيع
هجوم يسبقه تكتيك روسي جديد يتمثل في
اطلاق مناطيد تحمل عاكسات رادار فوق
اوكرانيا للحصول على معلومات بشان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني لاجبار كييف على
استنزاف مخزوناتها القيمه من الذخيره
وصواريخ ارض جو حسب الدفاع البريطانيه
لمواجهه ذلك الاوكرانيون فتحوا خطه تعبئه
طوعيه جديده وفق صحيفه الطعام الصحيفه
ذاتها نقلت عن مستشار زيلينسكي قوله ان
معركه السيطره على باخموت مهمه وان
اوكرانيا لن تتخلى عنها ابدا اذ تعتبرها
مفتاح الصراع ولا مجال لخسارتها فالسيطره
على باخموت ستشكل نقطه انطلاق بالنسبه
لروسيا للزحف نحو مدينتين اكبر هما اكرم
تورسك اللتين تقعان ابعد باتجاه الغرب في
دونيتسك ما سيعيد الزخم قبل الذكرى الاولى
لانطلاق الحرب ولتحقيق هذا الهدف تطالب
اوكرانيا حلفائها الغربيين بالمزيد من
الطائرات المقاتله والدبابات الحربيه
المتقدمه في وقت تؤكد كياف انها تحتاج
ايضا صواريخ بعيده المدى لصد الهجوم
الروسي واستعاده السيطره على المناطق التي
خسرتها فالجيش الاوكراني يستهلك القذائف
بوتيره اسرع مما يمكن للغرب ان يصنع حسب
رويترز ما يمثل عقبه اخرى امام قوتكياف
خلال المرحله المقبله بلال البجدين
العربيه
الصين تتدخل بشكل مباشر في الحرب
الاوكرانيه لدعم حليفتها روسيا والحديث
هنا لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي من مدينه
ميونخ الالمانيه
ان الشركات الصينيه تقدم بالفعل دعما
باسلحه غير قتاليه فيما جديد المعلومات
يشير الى ان بكين يمكن ان تقدم دعما قاتلا
وبينما حذر بلنكن بكين من عواقب وخيمه
عليها اذا اقدمت على تقديم الدعم لروسيا
تنفي الصين بشكل كامل التقارير التي تحدثت
عن ان روسيا طلبت منها معدات عسكريه
استعدادا للمعارك المقبله في اوكرانيا قبل
ذلك وبعيدا عن وسائل الاعلام التقى وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بنظيره الصيني الذي اكد
لبلينكن ان العلاقات بين البلدين تضررت
بسبب طريقه تعامل واش مع احاديث المنطاد
وحضى الجانب الامريكي على تغيير المسار
واصلاح الضرر الذي تسبب فيه ما سماه
الاستخدام المفرط للقوه للعلاقات بين بكين
وواشنطن بحسب قول الوزير الصيني
كنا نراقب هذا عن كثب وحتى الان راينا
شركات صينيه وهناك لا فرق بين الشركات
الخاصه والدوله رايناهم يقدمون دعما
باسلحه غير مميته لروسيا لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا القلق الان يعتمد على المعلومات
التي لدينا عن انهم يفكرون في تقديم اسلحه
قاتله
والان نواب جمهوريون وكذلك ديمقراطيون
يطالبون اداره الرئيس بايدن بارسال
مقاتلات اف 16 لاوكرانيا تلك التي كنا
نقول للتو بان زيلينسكي يقاتل من اجل
الحصول عليها
قالت في تقرير لها ان الطائرات دون طيار
الصينيه تدعم الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وفقا لبيانات تجاريه بالاضافه الى بيانات
التصدير اظهرت عده مقاطع مصوره مقاتلين
روسا يستخدمون طائرات بدون طيار من طراز
دي جي اي الصينيه في اوكرانيا ما يوفر
لموسكو طريقه فعاله لاستهداف القوات
الاوكرانيه وفقا لمسؤولين غربيين ومحللين
امنيين وعدا عن المردود المادي من بيع
الطائرات باضعاف سعرها بامكان الصين عبر
المسيرات ان تجمع معلومات استخباراتيه في
ساحه المعركه
ترى كيفيه استجابه هذه الطائرات لهجمات
الحرب الالكترونيه شركه دي جي اي قالت في
بيان لها انها تعارض استخدام طائراتها
المدنيه في ساحه المعركه مشيره الى تعليق
اعمالها في روسيا واوكرانيا في ابريل من
العام الماضي رغم ذلك اشارت الى انه يمكن
شراء منتجات الشركه من متاجر التجاره
الالكترونيه في العديد من البلدان وانه لا
يمكن منع المستخدمين او المؤسسات من
الشراء بدورها اشارت سفاره الصين في
واشنطن ردا على تقرير وولد الى موقف وزاره
الخارجيه من الحرب في اوكرانيا والداعي
للتفاوض ووقف التصعيد بينما امتنعت وزاره
الدفاع والخارجيه الروسيتان عن التعليق
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا ستتسلم 50 دبابه فقط من اصل
320 وعد بها الغرب بحلول ابريل
نناقش الشانين الصيني والامريكي وما
بينهما مع الصحفي نادي من بكين اهلا بك
معنا استاذ نادر يعني اريد ان اسالك اولا
عن تنبيه الولايات المتحده الصين من مغبه
ارسال اسلحه الى روسيا
رغم النفي الصيني الا ان هذا يثير الكثير
من القلق من امكانيه انخراط الصين بشكل
مباشر في الصراع ما رايك
اهلا ومرحبا بكم اولا الموقف الصين تجاه
الازمه في اوكرانيا
واضحه ومستمر ودائم وهو
الصين تدعو الى
تدعو كل الاتراف الى
الوقف اطلاق النار
والعوده الى طاولات المفاوضات وايجار حل
سلمي وسياسي
عفوا عبر التفاوت والحوار
وهذا هو معكم الصيني ثابت تجاهها الازمه
في اوكرانيا فلذلك اذا اين تضع تحت اي
خانه تضع كلام وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بشكل مباشر لنظيره الصيني
عندما قال ان تنظر في ارسال اسلحه الى
روسيا دعما لهجومها في اوكرانيا تحديدا
فهذا
ايضا
[موسيقى]
من
الاتهامات امريكيه ضد الصين في هذا الجانب
وفاسين التم في ذلك وكذلك
لن تقبل
الضغوط الولايات المتحده او حتى المضايقات
مثل هذه
فالسين لن تقدم اي دعم عسكري او نقول لا
تقدم اي اسلحه لاي طرف من النزاع المسلحه
الصين موقف الصين هو التعزيز التفاوض من
اجل ايجاد حال سلمي
معلومات عن خطه التفاوض التي تريد الصين
ان تدخلها الى طرفي النزاع على الاقل
حسب
التصريحات
كبير دبلوماسيين الصينيين ان الصين ستعلن
الاجراءات الملموسه لخطه الصين لاحلال
السلام في ابي خصوص ازمه اوكرانيا
وهو ايضا تاكد ان الصين مبدا الصين هو
دعوه التراث المختلفه الى الايجاد حل سلمي
ولكن هل ستتمكن من ذلك اليس الطرفا حتى لو
لم تنخرط مباشره في هذا الصراع حتى لو ثبت
انها لم تنخرط مباشره اليست طرفا على
الصعيد الدولي على الساحه العالميه في
اطار صراع الاقطاب الحالي
طبعا المختلف الاطراف الطرف يعني هو من
اجل
تحيات الظروف للتفاوض بدلا من التقديم
اسلحه لتسعيده فترى في اي دوله مسؤوله يجب
ان تراعي الامن والسلامه الحياه المواطنين
في اوكرانيا وكذلك
المعاناه الشعوب في الدول
الاوروبيه هذا اولا بدلا من
اي اسلحه لاي طرف لاجل مغسله المثال رغم
ان الاتهامات الامريكيه للصين يعني لا تقل
شراسه في موضوع التسليح والتجسس
والتنصت وارسال المناطيد الى قارات العالم
وهو ما نسالك عنه بعد قليل
اضافه الى ما تحدث عنه الجنرال الامريكي
برادلي تشانس
وقائد عمليات الفضاء في سلاح الجو
الامريكي الذي اعتبر ان ما سماه سباق
التسلح المضطرد في الفضاء شهد تحولا
جوهريا واوضح خلال مشاركته في مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن ان الصين اصبحت تشكل تهديدا كبيرا
امام روسيا في مجال التسلح الفضائي واشار
تشانس الذي يعمل قائدا لعمليات الفضاء في
سلاح الجو الامريكي الى ان خصومه امريكا
الاستراتيجيين يمتلكون مجموعه كامله من
الاسلحه وعلى راسهم الصين وروسيا كما اكد
الضابط الامريكي رفيع المستوى ان النزاع
في اوكرانيا اوضح اهميه الفضاء الكبيره في
حروب اليوم والغد
من جهتها حذرت بكين واشنطن من انها ستكون
مسؤوله عن كل العواقب في حال تصعيد الخلاف
بشان ازمه المنطاد الذي اسقطته القوات
الجويه الامريكيه وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه
انها ستقوم بالمتابعه حتى النهايه حال
اصرت الولايات المتحده على استغلال هذا
الامر
نعود الى صحفي نادي الرونج من بكين ارحب
بك مجددا بلنكن قالها صراحه
بانكي لم يعتذر له عندما التقاه عن حادثه
المنطاد رغم تاكيد الولايات المتحده عبر
مختلف المسؤولين الامريكيين انها اسقطت
منطادا كان معدا من قبل بكين للتجسس
لماذا باعتقادك لم ترد الصين ان تهدئ من
الامور قليلا
او اولا الصين يعني اسلا تريد تهدئه
الوضع والتوتر بهذه هذا السبب
لاند اعربه اسفها
وكذلك اكدت مراره تكرارا ان هذا هذه
الحادثه هي حادثه غير مقصود وخارجه غير
متوقعه وخارج اراده الصين
وثم هذا المنطاد ليس من اجل التجسس وهو من
مدني
للبحوثات العلميه
فعود حدث في المراره ولكن الولايات
المتحده لا تعطيكم بذلك بمثواهم وهي مصره
على اسقاطها بالقوه وبمبالغه في هذا الامر
فحتى في حال اكدت
متحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان لا
يشكل خطرا على امن الولايات المتحده
في كل هذه الاحوال الولايات المتحده مصره
على اسقاطها وكذلك مبالغه في هذا الامر
وافراط في استخدام انتم تتحدثون
افراط فاستخدام القوه بينما يعني ما فعلته
الولايات المتحده كان اسقاطا لمنطاد كان
يشكل خطر على امنها وربما كان للتجسس وكل
المسؤولين يقولون ذلك الان في الولايات
المتحده على الاقل يعني اين الافراط في
استخدام القوه هل من العادل بكين ان تشهد
وصول مناطيد من هذا النوع او اجهزه تجسس
اخرى وقد اتهمت الغرب بذلك فعلا من قبل
ولكن ان تتركها هل هذا عادي اليس من
الطبيعي ان تقوم الولايات المتحده بمقامه
به
هذا الامر يعني ليس بالجديد بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده فهو هناك مناطق
الامريكيه مره يعني انتهت الاجواء الصينيه
بدون مره بدون اذن من الحكومه الصينيه
لاكثر من عشر مرات في العام الماضي الصين
لم اتكم
باستخدام لقوه لاسقادها فاذا كان
الامريكيه الصادقه اتجاه الصين فيجب عليها
البقاء الاتصال تواصل مع الصين وتاكد منها
والمعالجه معا بحذر
يعني باسلوب اكثر التخصصا من هذا وكذلك
[موسيقى]
يجبد ولكن انت تؤكد الان بان الصين لم
تكن تسقط كل اجهزه واساليب التجسس تلك
التي تتهم بكين واشنطن بالقيام بها ماذا
كانت تفعل اذا يعني تتركها تتجسس على
امنها وعلى مواطنها
طبعا لا
المناطيط مثل هذا هو مناطيت يعني من اجل
ارصاد الجويه حتى الامم المتحده اكدت بان
مثل هذه من اجل الارصاد الجويه هو منتشر
في العالم واذا كان نحن نقوم باسقاطها
كلها يعني هناك سيكون هناك حوادث كثيره
ويعطل ايضا عمليه
الارصاد الجويه
البحوث العلميه فهذا كلام ليس من الصين
فهذا حسب التصريحات المسؤول او مامي فلذلك
مثل هذه المناطيط
هناك مبالغه في استخدام استخدام القوه
وكذلك
حتى يمكن ان نرى هناك تجسس الامريكيه يعني
الاستطلاع وهناك ايضا
اصطدام حتى هناك اصطدام بين
[موسيقى]
التارات الصيني مقاتلات الصينيه والطائرات
الامريكيه هذا قبل اكثر عشر من اكثر من
عشرين عاما
الولايات المتحده كانت
كذلك تدعم مع الصين بشكل غير متساويه
يعني حتى
الطيار الصيني في ذلك الوقت حياتهم بسبب
اصطدام وبسبب مراقبه التجسس الامريكيه
وبعد ذلك الولايات المتحده فقط اعتذر
واعاده كل طاقم
الطائر الى
الولايات المتحده وهذا ايضا هذه الحادثه
مثل يعني
على يعني كرامه امه جسينيه والصين لن
تسمحوا بحدوث هذا
الاخرى لذلك بهذا القدر واشكرك على وجودك
معنا استاذ نادي الرونق الصحفي من بكين
تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا
بالانكن يعايدو من انطاكيا بدعم تركيا
وبتخطي عراقيل العقوبات لمساعده السوريين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تركيا القت السلطات
الرايه البيضاء امام سيف الوقت واعلنت وقف
عمليات الانقاذ في كل المحافظات المنكوبه
باستثناء هاتاي وكهربا مرعش ومع تحول
العمليات من انقاذ الارواح الى انتشال
الجثث يتوقع ان يرتفع عدد القتلى بشكل
كبير وكنا قد عرضنا عليكم اخر الاخبار قبل
قليل عن ارتفاع هذا العدد بالفعل وفقا
للسلطات التركيه الى
41,020 قتيلا نقلا عن اداره الكوارث
التركيه التي حدثت ارقام القتلى
لترتفع اذا الى
41,2020 قتيلا الازمه هنا انه لا توجد
ارقام محدده عن عدد المفقودين
لكن لدى الاتراك رقم بديل له دلاله كبيره
ومؤسفه
350 الف شقه دمرت بالكامل وهو ما يعني ان
هذا الرقم المعلن
حول مقتل قرابه واحد واربعين الفا ما يزال
بعيدا وقد يكون بعيدا جدا عن ان يكون رقما
نهائيا
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الامريكيه اعلنت تقديم 100 مليون
دولار جديده لتركيا وسوريا دعما لجهود
الاغاثه بعد الزلزال وتعهد وزير الخارجيه
انتوني بلينكن خلال زيارته لتركيا بتقديم
كل الدعم لانقره كما اكد ان واشنطن ستعمل
على ضمان ان لا تعرقل العقوبات على سوريا
تدفق المساعدات
نحن مصممون على بذل كل ما في وسعنا
لمساعده الشعب التركي والشعب السوري ايضا
وسنبذل كل جهدنا لتحقيق ذلك نحن متاثرون
جدا بما اصابهم كل ما اريد ان يعرفه شعب
تركيا هو ان الولايات المتحده تقف الى
جانبهم وسنظل معهم حتى يتجاوزون ازمتهم
مهما استغرق الامر من وقت
بالتزامن مع وصول اربعه عشره شاحنه محمله
بالخيام للمشردين جراء الزلزال شمال غرب
سوريا دعت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود الى زياده
المساعدات الانسانيه للمنطقه المنكوبه
بشكل عاجل وحذر رئيس بعثه المنظمه الى
سوريا حكيم خالدي من ان مخزون الطوارئ لدى
المنظمه نفذ خلال ثلاثه ايام لافتا الى
عدم ملاحظته اي دعم من الخارج ومنتقدا
تراجع المساعدات عما كانت عليه قبل
الزلزال
اكثر من اربعه ملايين سوري في مناطق
الزلزال شمال البلاد في خطر جديد
الخطر سببه نقص المساعدات والمواد اللازمه
لما بعد الكارثه
هذه المساعدات تتمثل بتامين الماوى
والمياه النظيفه والامدادات الطبيه
للعمليات الجراحيه
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود اطلقت نداء جديدا
لاغاثه المنطقه
المنظمه افرغت مخزونها في الايام الثلاثه
الاولى من الكارثه
تقول المنظمه ان المساعدات الخارجيه اقل
من معدلها الاسبوعي عام 2022
مؤخرا منظمه الغذاء العالمي اتهمت سلطات
المنطقه بعرقله ادخال المساعدات
معنا من اسطنبول مفرد العربيه عبد القادر
خربوش ومن ريف ادلب الصحفي محمد الاشقر
اهلا بكما ابدا معك عبد القادر واريد يعني
ان اعرف ابرز ما يمكن رصده من اجواء طبعا
كلها لا زال يخيم عليها شبح الزلزال بكل
المفاصل التي يمكن ان تعيشها تركيا يوميا
هذه الايام ما بعد الزلزال ما ابرز ما
يمكن رصده مع ارتفاع عدد القتلى وفقا
لاداره الكوارث التركيه الى
41,020 قتيلا
نعم طاهر اجواء الزلزال لا تزال تخين على
الشارع التركي هنا باسطنبول ايضا اكبر
المدن التركيه تعدادا للسكان انتقل اليها
شبح الخوف من الزلزال هي الاخرى الصحف
المحليه هنا تتحدث عن احتمال وقوع زلزال
اخر هذا كان تحذير منذ سنوات للخبراء لكنه
عاد ليتداول هذه الايام طبعا تزامنا مع
حجم الكارثه او هول الزلزال المدمر الذي
لا يزال عداده مستمرا في الارتفاع لضحايا
القتلى فهناك يعني مخاوف لدى سكان اسطنبول
بالخصوص الاحياء العتيقه منها والمباني
بعد تحذير ايضا عمده المدينه من احتمال
انهيار هذه المباني عند اول تحرك للارض مع
احتمال هذه الزلازل التي يتحدث عنها
الخبراء بالاضافه طبعا الى
تحرك اخر من الشق السياسي والاقتصادي ايضا
لاداره هذه الازمه من قبيل المعارضه التي
بدات تحضر نوعا ما لما بعد الكارثه وتريد
ان لا تطمس هذه الكارثه فقط في يعني في
منحاها الطبيعي فحسب بدات تتحدث عن
المسائله عن تحديد المسؤوليه عن عدم
الاسراع في ازاله الاثار هذه الكارثه قبل
ان يبدا الادعاء العام او يتم فتح تحقيقات
في اسباب انهيار هذا العدد الكبير من
المباني اليوم تم الاعلان عن نتيجه المسح
المبدئي لحجم الاضرار والذي مسقوا رابط
ثلاث ملايين شقه سكنيه
بين الانهيار الكلي والانهيار الجزئي
والادرار الخفيفه التي مست هذه الوحدات
السكنيه من مجموع حوا ما يقارب مليون
بنايه سكنيه طبعا هناك اجراءات في الجانب
الاخر حكوميه سريعه متسارعه لاحتواء اثار
هذه الازمه عبر بناء المساكن الجاهزه
المؤقته التي تسعى لان تصل الى حدود 100
الف مسكن لحد الان يتم العمل على 30 الف
مسكن الى غايه شهر مارس اذار القادم وايضا
تم نصب حوالي 250 الف خيمه اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه كل هذه الاجراءات الان
تقابلها في الجانب الاخر بدء تحضير لما
يصطلح عليه
بالمسائله وتحديد المسؤوليات تبقى معنا
انتقل الان الى محمد الاشقر يعني اعتقد
على الجانب السوري
في المناطق التي تضررت كثيرا من الزلزال
ليس هناك حتى يعني رفاهيه بين قوسين توقع
او الخوف او الانتظار لحدوث زلزال اخر كما
هو حال القلق في الداخل التركي بسبب
الانشغال الكبير في يعني لملمه جروح
وتداعيات ما حصل كيف تبدو الصوره عندك
الان
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هناك العديد من المدن
والبلدات المدمره يعني من الممكن ان تسمى
منكوبه وعلى وعلى راسها مدينه جنديرس في
ريف عفرين الشمالي هذه المدينه بالفعل لا
يوجد فيها يعني لا يملك
المتبقون فيها رفاهيه الخوف من
من اي هزات ارتداديه اخرى ولكن في معظم
بلدات ومدن شمال غرب سوريا طبعا يعيش
الاهالي هنا
اللحظات من الخوف الشديد من اي هزه
ارتداديه خصوصا ان الهزات الارتداديه
تتكرر بين الحين والاخر دعني ان اذكر لك
اخر هزه ارتداديه شعر بها سكان شمال غرب
سوريا كانت ليله الخميس يعني اغلب الاهالي
تركوا منازلهم ونزلوا الى الشوارع خوفا من
هذه الهزات الارتداديه طبعا العديد من
المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
تركوا منازلهم المتصدعه وذهبوا ليقطنوا في
مراكز الايوى او حتى في المخيمات
المستحدثه يعني خوفا من اي هزه ارتداديه
قد تحصل قد تتسبب بانهيار منزلهم المتصدع
طبعا هذه الحاله هنا نتيجه
عدوه لحظه وقوع الزلزال لحظه وقوع هذه
الكارثه طبعا يعني الفئه الاكثر خوفا هنا
الاطفال يعني اغلب الاطفال يعانون من من
صدمه يعني هناك حاله خوف كبيره من المنازل
يعني هنا في شمال غرب سوريا الاغلب اصبح
يجد في الخيمه
يعني ماوى اكثر امنا من المنزل بعد ان كان
المنزل حلما للكثير من السوريين قاطني
الخيام في شمال غرب سوريا الان قلبت
الموازين واصبحت الخيمه حلما لجميع
السوريين هنا في شمال غرب سوريا وخصوصا
المشردين منهم المتضررين الذين لجاوا الى
مراكز الايواء المؤقته او المخيمات
المستحدثه هنا اتحدث عن الاف العائلات
التي
لازالت تعيش يعيش الكثير منها في المخيمات
المستحدثه في كل خيمه منهم يعني تقطن اكثر
من عائله نتيجه قله الماوى مراكز الايواء
لا يزال يوجد الكثير من مراكز الايواء
التي يفصل فيها الرجال عن النساء لاستيعاب
اكبر عدد ممكن من
المتضررين ولو مؤقتا يعني هنا تفصل
العائله عن بعضها وفي هذه الاوقات يعني
اشد ما تكون له العائله ان تكون
اشد يعني الحاجه الاساسيه للعائله للعائله
ان تكون مجتمعه مع بعض
حقيقه يعني اوضاع
انسانيه صعبه يعانيها يعانيها المتضررون
الذين لجاوا الى هذه المخيمات يعني
في هذه الماساه حقها للاسف ولكن لا زلنا
نحاول شكرا جزيلا لك محمد الاشقر الصحفي
من ادلب وعبد القادر خربوش موفد العربيه
الى اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك وسنتابع في 360
من ما كنت تتحدث عنه قبل قليل حول المخاوف
في الداخل التركي من حدوث زلزال اخر خاصه
في اسطنبول زلزال تركيا وسوريا طرح اسئله
حول ما يمكن حدوثه اذا ضرب زلزال مشابه
اسطنبول العاصمه الاقتصاديه لتركيا
التداعيات المباشره لا يمكن تخيلها في
اكبر مدن تركيا وفي اكثرها اكتظاظا
بالسكان والتي تمثل 50% من الاقتصاد
التركي
بحسب باحثين فالمنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه من
اوروبا الى الشرق الاوسط عرضه للزلازل
فيما المنطقه المحيطه باسطنبول جزء من صدع
شمال الاناضول النشط واي زلزال يمكن ان
يتسبب باضرار كبيره جدا التوقعات تشير الى
ان اسطنبول قد تتعرض لزلزال بقوه سبع
درجات او اكثر خلال الاعوام المقبله وان
تتجاوز خسائر هذا الزلزال زلزال السادس من
فبراير الاخير بعد هذا الزلزال تحدثنا
كثيرا عن قوانين البناء او ما يسمى بكود
البناء في تركيا لمقاومه الزلازل فماذا عن
اسطنبول في حال حدوث زلزال فيها المشكله
في اسطنبول تكمل في ان السبعين في المئه
من مبانيها بنيت قبل عام الفين اي عندما
لم تكن هناك عمليات تفتيش للتحقق من
مقاومتها للزلازل
لنفصل بعض الارقام اكثر
اكثر من 250 الفا من مباني اسطنبول شيد
قبل عام
1980 اكثر من ضعف هذا الرقم هو لمبان
اقيمت بين عامي
1980 والفين الجزء المتبقي وهو 376 الف
مبنى تاسس بعد عام 2000 الرقم هذا والذي
يمثل 30% من مباني اسطنبول لا يعني انها
امنه تماما راينا في هذا الزلزال الاخير
عندما سقطت مباني فاخره مشيده حديثا بفعل
الزلزال والتي قيل انها كانت متوافقه مع
لوائح الزلازل اثناء البناء
[موسيقى]
اذا وقع زلزال في اسطنبول تسود الخشيه من
ان ما يزيد عن خمسين الف مبنى سيتضرر مع
احتمال مقتل 200 الف شخص في اسوا
التقديرات لكن هل يمكن نقل السكان الى
مساكن امنه الجواب بحسب وسائل الاعلام
التركيه على الاقل نعم فعدد المنازل
الشاغره كاف لاعاده اسكان الذين يقطنون في
مباني شديده الخطوره الا ان القرار هنا
يعود للسلطات التركيه التي لم تتخذ هذا
القرار حتى الان على الاقل الحكومه انشات
بعد زلزال تسعه وتسعين من القرن الماضي ما
اسمته ضريبه الزلازل لتحسين مقاومه
المباني المشيده في المدن
الاحصاءات تشير الى جمع ما يقارب 38 مليار
دولار من خلال هذه الضريبه الخاصه لجعل
المدن التركيه مقاومه للزلازل المعارضه
التركيه قالت ان الاموال المجموعه لم
تستخدم بشكل صحيح وان حكومات حزب العداله
والتنميه برئاسه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
جيرت الاموال لتغطيه نفقات حكوميه اخرى
اشارت المعارضه ايضا الى ان قانون الكوارث
اعطى الحكومه حق المصادره باسم حمايه
السكان من الزلازل لكن تم استخدام هذا
القانون للاستحواذ على اراض سعرها عالا في
اسطنبول مع تصاعد المخاوف اطلق رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو حمله لهدم
المباني القديمه واعاده انشائها لتمكينها
من مواجهه اي زلزال محتمل بدورها كثفت
هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه من
التمارين على اساس الاستجابه لسيناريو
يضرب فيه زلزال بقوه سبع درجات ونصف او
اعلى مدينه اسطنبول والتركيز على الاحياء
التي من المتوقع ان تكون الاكثر تاثرا باي
زلزال قادم في اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
اذا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقول ان سلاح
الجو الاسرائيليه نفذ ضربه في دمشق
باستخدام اربع مقاتلات اف 16 عشر كان
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان نقل قبل قليل
ان من ضمن القتلى في القصف الاسرائيلي على
دمشق ان من ضمنهم عسكريين بينهم ثلاثه
ضباط
نقلت عند دبلوماسيين قولهم ان المراقبين
الدوليين رصدوا في ايران الاسبوع الماضي
يورانيوم مخصبا الى مستويات تقترب من صنع
سلاح نوويه وقال ديبلوماسيان ليبلومبرغ ان
اليورانيوم وصلت درجه نقائه الى
84% وهو اعلى مستوى وجده المفتشون في
البلاد حتى الان حيث تحتاج ايران الى
زياده هذه النسبه بسته بالمئه فقط
للوصول لسلاح نووي
ورغم ان اسرائيل كعادتها لم تتبنى الهجوم
الاخيره على سوريا بشكل مباشر لكن رئيس
وزرائها بنيامين نتنياهو خرج برساله لافته
في التوقيت اتهم ايران بمحاوله ايذاء
اسرائيل ومواطنها متعهدا بالتصدي لها بكل
الطرق
ايران تحاول ايذاء اسرائيل ومواطنيها
اينما كانوا في العالم بلا هوادا هجمات
ايران لن تضبط عزيمتنا لن نسمح لايران
بامتلاك اسلحه نوويه ولا نسمح لها
بالتمركز على طول حدودنا الشماليه نفعل كل
شيء وسنبدو القصار جهدنا لحمايه مواطنينا
ونرد بشده على الهجمات ضدنا
هذا ونفت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه سقوط
قتل ايرانيين في الضربه الاسرائيليه على
دمشق وريفها بسوريا واكدت وكاله ايرنا عدم
وقوع اضرار في مجمع للخمينيه والمدرسه
الايرانيه في دمشق وقالت ان الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على دمشق نفذ على مرحلتين
الاولى في دمشق والثانيه في السويداء
واضافت ان الصاروخ الاسرائيلي سقط في
الموقع نفسه الذي قتل فيه عماد دمغنيه احد
اهم القاده العسكريين لحزب الله عام 2008
تصاعد ملحوظ للضربات الاسرائيليه على
اهداف في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
استهداف صاروخي تخترق به اسرائيل الاجواء
السوريه بهدف الوصول لمواقع ومنشات
وعناصره تابعه لايران الاستهداف الثاني
خلال العام الجاري هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي
طار كفر سوسه الحي السكني في دمشق وراحه
ضحيته 15 شخصا وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان تلك الصواريخ الاسرائيليه استهدفت
مواقع تتمركز فيها ميليشيات ايرانيه وحزب
الله اللبناني ويعد هذا الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي الثاني خلال العام الجاري ففي
الثاني من يناير الماضي قتل سبعه عناصر
جراء الضربات الاسرائيليه على مطار دمشق
الدولي ومحيطه
وتيره الهجمات الاسرائيليه على اهداف داخل
سوريا وثقها المرصد السوري بحوالي 32
استهدافا خلال العام الماضي وحده قامت
خلالها اسرائيل باستهداف الاراضي السوريه
سواء عبر ضربات صاروخيه او جويه اسفرت عن
اصابه وتدمير نحو 91 هدفا عسكريا
معنا الان من الناصره وديعه واودي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك معنا استاذ وديع
معلومات المرصد السوري تقول بانه عدد ممن
قتل سبعه من ضمن القتلى في القصف
الاسرائيلي على دمشق عسكريون بينهم ثلاثه
ضباط ايضا هناك معلومات عن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تقول انه سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
نفذت ضربه في دمشق باستخدام اربع مقاتلات
اف 16 اولا ماذا تقول هذه المعلومات
بالنسبه اليك واذا ما اضفنا اليها
المعلومات الوارده على الاقل في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي ماذا يمكن ان نفهم من هذه
الضربه تحديدا
قولا اخي العزيز مساء الخير واضح ان هذه
الضربه وهذه المعطيات وهذه التسريبات وهذه
البيانات
متعدده المصادر تقول ان هناك اختراق كبير
في سوريا وفي ايران تستطيع الاستخبارات
العسكريه ان تستهدف هذه المواقع وهذه
الاهداف بدقه وبسرعه فائقه بشكل متكرر مما
يشي بان هناك يعني عمليه سيطره
استخباراتيه اسرائيليه لا يساهم بها في
هذه الناحيه الامر الثاني هو اللافت طبعا
هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الشهور الاخيره
ليس فقط من حيث الكم انما من حيث استعداد
اساسا الاسرائيليين للمجاهره كان على سبيل
المثال رئيس حكومه اسرائيل السابقه او
الاسبق يهود اولمر رئيسا للحكومه عام 2007
حينما استهدفت اسرائيل دير الزور في شمال
سوريا وكان هناك حديث عن مشروع نووي سوري
واظلت العمليه طي الكتمان بعد سنوات طويله
ورفض ان يتحدث بالموضوع بينما هنا الان
نجد دينك ياهو يكاد ان يعترف بملء الفم
بان يعني الطيران الاسرائيلي هو الذي قام
بمثل هذا العمليه الليله وان هذا حلقه في
مسلسل طويل كان وسيكون في من اجل حمايه
مواطنين اسرائيل ومنع الاذى الايراني وما
الى ذلك وهذا يقول ان نتنياهو ليس يعني
غبيا او مغامرا فهو يدرك ان مثل هذا
التحرش بايران من حيث انه يحشر يعني يحشر
ايران بالزاويه وربما يدفعها لمحاوله
الانتقام لان هذا نوع من الاصبع بالعين
حينما يقول ولو كان بالتلميح الغليظ وليس
بالتصريح لكنه يحرج ايران انا اعتقد ان
ذلك ياتي على خلفيه مشاكل الداخليه
العاصفه في اسرائيل التي من خلالها يحاول
نتنياهو كسب النقاط ليقول انه قادر على ان
يكون سيد الامن ان يقود اسرائيل الى تحدي
ايران وكسر هذه المعادله محاوله تحويل حزب
الله الى لاعب
قوي خطير في المنطقه يكسر قواعد اللعبه
التقليديه ولكن ياتي بعد هذه الضربه
مباشره معلومات يعني نضيفها الى الضربه
وامكانيات كل ما
سينتج عنها ما نقلته صحيفه اسرائيل
الامريكي لدى اسرائيل توماس يقول بامكان
اسرائيل بل وينبغي لها ان تفعل كل ما
ينبغي للتعامل مع ايران ونحن نساندهم هذا
في الشق الاول اضافه الى المعلومات التي
وردت قبل قليل عن اكتشاف يعني يورانيوم
مخصب بنسبه نقاء تصل الى
84% وهو رقم عالم جدا كيف باعتقادك يمكن
لاسرائيل ان تتصرف بناء عليه البعض قد
يذهب الى فكره التصعيد والبعض قد يذهب الى
ما هو مناقض لذلك على اعتبار بان ايران
اصبح من المسلم انها اقتربت جدا ان لم تكن
قادره فعلا على صنع سلاح نووي
اولا بما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كان لها طالما كان لها هذا
الموقف المساند لاسرائيل بالذات في دعم
جهودها ضد ايران وضد مساعى ايران للتمدد
المنطقه وضد استهلاك اسلحه نوويه باعتبار
ان هناك مصالح مشتركه هناك مصالح امريكيه
كبيره خاصه في منطقه الخليج التي تستهدف
وتهدف من قبل ايران الامر الثاني الذي جعل
من ولايه المتحده الامريكيه اكثر قربا من
اسرائيل ودعما ومجاهره بهذا الدعم ضد
ايران والتدخل ايران في مساعده روسيا في
حربها على اوكرانيا من حيث ما انتهى
بالسلاح والطائرات المسيره والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بادارتها الحاليه مهتمه
جدا بما يدور في اوكرانيا وفي هذه الحرب
ولذلك هي يعني باتت اكثر راضيكليه في
تعاملها مع ايران وفي استعدادها لدعم
اسرائيل هل كانت اسرائيل بعد هذا البيان
وبعد هذه المعلومات الخطيره التي تتحدث عن
قرب طهران من امتلاك السلاح النووي ان
اسرائيل الى ما كانت تريد ان تكون به منذ
سنوات على الاقل كما افادت تسريبات
اسرائيليه انا اعتقد ان نتنياهو سيد بذلك
فرصه ثمينه كي ينجو بنفسه من هذه
الاحتجاجات المتواسعه التي فاجات اوساط
واسعه من اليمين ومن المنتخبين لكود
منتخبين يخرجون الى الشوارع وبالذات يوم
غدا لموعد مع مظاهره غير مسبوقه في كبرها
وفي ساعتها ولكن وانا اقرا يعني الكثير من
التحليلات والتعليقات وراء السطور لساته
ومسؤولين اسرائيليين سابقين وحاليين لن
تقوى اسرائيل على فعل ذلك الطيران بمشروع
استراتيجي بمعنى مهاجمه ايران
ومنشاتها نوويه الا بضوء اخضر امريكي
وبتعاون ربما يكون عسكري واستخباراتي
ودبلوماسي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه القراءه
استاذ وديعه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
الناصره تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا فيها طائره تركيه ما
اسوا ان تنفخ بالونا ولا ياتيك من يلعب به
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 من قناه خبر
ترك لا توجد اي امكانيات تشريعيه لتاجيل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقرره
في الثامن عشر من يونيو المقبل هذا ما
تنقله القناه عن اغلب الاحزاب التركيه
وتضيف ان احزاب المعارضه ترى الفرصه سانحه
امامها للفوز استغلالا لمازق الحكومه بعد
الزلزال بينما يؤمن حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم ان الانتقادات الشعبيه لن تطول
وانه يمثل الاستقرار المطلوب الان وبشده
لتجاوز الازمه والبدء باعاده الاعمار
كارثه الزلزال تحولت الى عمله بوجهين يرى
فيها كل طرف من الوجه الذي يريده ويتغاضى
عن الطرف الاخر
فيديو اليوم من هاتاي التركيه حيث بادر
متطوعون الى ربط عدد من البالونات فوق
الابنيه المهدمه تخليدا لذكرى كل طفل قتل
في الكارثه والخطه هي ان تتحول الانقاض
الى بحر من البالونات الحمراء كانت فكره
المصور اجونكور جيده لكنها لم تكن ابدا
سهله والكلام له في كل مره نربط فيها
بالونا يتالم قلبي المهمه لا تزال شاقه
امام عقور ورفاقه فما ربط حتى الان يعد
بين الف او يعد بين الف والف وخمسمائه
بينما اجمالي عدد القتلى في تركيا تخطى
واحدا واربعين الفا
وصوره اليوم من هاتاي التركيه ايضا تخشى
البقاء لكنها لا تقدر على الرحيل فبين
لحظه واخرى قد ياتي الخبر تجرف الاليات
اكوام الانقاض لاستخراج الجثث بعد ان بات
انتشال الاحياء اقرب الى الخيال ايا كانت
الديون نحو الاحبه لم يعد هناك ما يمكن
الوفاء به سوى دين الاخير تشييعهم للمثوى
الاخير
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمتابعتكم العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار
الساعه لا تنقطع ويوافينا بالمزيد منها
صهيب شراير الان صهيب الكلمه لك مجددا
ماذا لديك شكرا لك طاهر نستكمل اذا في هذه
الفتره المسائيه في اخبار الساعه اخبار
هذا اليوم في الصداره تبقى الحرب في
اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده تحذر ان الصين
ربما تتجه لتقديم اسلحه لروسيا معك تفضل
شكرا لك